depuis ce week-end plus de 80 mille
personnes ont été évacuées du donbass
des exilés qui se sont réfugiés en
russie comment ont-ils accueilli la
locution et hier soir de vladimir
poutine éléments de réponse avec notre
envoyé spécial dans la région de rostov
de rabelais raziq le cdt aérium de ce
média est un des nombreux centres
d'accueil mis à disposition des réfugiés
ici dans la région de rostov sur le don
ce pensionnat transformer en hébergement
provisoire peut accueillir jusqu'à 300
personnes des femmes et des enfants
principalement alors les y trouve un peu
de réconfort de quoi se nourrir de quoi
faire leur toilette et puis passait une
voire deux nuit en attendant d'être
évacués vers d'autres régions de russie
alors il faut savoir qu'au total dans la
région de rostov sur le don nous sommes
actuellement frontalière du don ba 118
centres temporaires on veut le jour
comme celui-ci ils sont occupés par plus
de 7000 personnes dont environ trois
mille deux cents enfants les autres
réfugiés qui traversent la frontière et
bien vont être évacués par train vers
d'autres régions de russie ils ont
d'ailleurs pris le train des bus voir
leurs propres moyens pour arriver
jusqu'ici dans cette région de rostov
sur le don en attendant nous avons
rencontré justement ces réfugiés qui se
trouvent ici dans ce pensionnat et bien
tous sont reconnaissants de l'aide
apportée par la russie je vous propose
d'écouter ces quelques témoignages
mon fils m'a appelé il vit en russie il
a même appelé et il a dit maman tu as vu
à la télé et il pleurait de joie qu'ils
aient signé
nous sommes très bien ici il nous
bichonnent tout le temps il demande sans
arrêt avez vous besoin de quelque chose
les volontaires et les enfants arrivent
laissez-nous faire quelque chose pour
vous la chambre est nettoyé tout effet
de quoi d'autre avons nous besoin on
mange très bien nous pouvons nous
reposer autant que nous le voulons on
peut aller se promener autant qu'on le
jeu
nous sommes très heureux nous avons même
pleuré hier nous y voilà enfin
nous sommes très heureux merci à poutine
à tout le peuple russe qui nous a si
bien accueilli on ne nous fait pas de
mal nous nous sentons bien ici nous
sommes à l'aise ici
nous avons pleuré nous nous sommes
réjouis car tout devrait aller bien pour
nous maintenant au total depuis vendredi
près de 70 mille civils ont fui les
régions autoproclamées de donetsk et de
lugan sa cause à des frappes du
chrétienne rien que sur ces dernières 24
heures selon les services de sécurité
plus de vingt mille personnes ont
traversé la frontière avec le donbass